friend of belsen you're just in time
this purl resists a few insignificant
echoes and a name to apply to it but
nothing to tell us who created it or
what kind of magic it employs it isn't
Daedric in origin though despite the
force al darks allegiance it's time to
utilize more drastic means we're about
to enter a crucial stage of the augury
ritual so none of us can leave this
chamber if you could find my acolyte or
a Andra she'll provide you with the
amplification elixir we require she's in
Sothis sealed study upstairs
Oriana should be in sofa seals chambers
cataloging his old research and
experiments tell her I need the
amplification elixir to strengthen our
augury ritual that should help us
determine what the Pearl is and where it
came from leader implies command and a
level of structure more suited to an
army than an order of mystic monks that
said I oversee the siddik order and our
Conclave of the eleven forces someone
must steer the ship after all you have
traveled across the mystic realms to
reach the island we call Artyom as an
uninitiated this may sound confusing but
the civic order changes the location of
its headquarters on occasion and by that
I mean we move the entire island Tamriel
my friend
you left the boundaries of nirn behind
the ritual has while the majority
you must be the adventurer that Bowser
and was going on about allow me to be
the first to welcome you to our secret
island oh I suppose you already talked
to the right master seeing as you're
here in Kippur Tower that strange pearl
has certainly been reluctant to reveal
its secrets the right master hates it
when an inanimate object refuses to
cooperate regarding the amplification
elixir
I just catalogued it it's a Sothis eel
creation as you'd expect hmm what no not
in the traditional sense he's not one of
our mouths
if that's what you're asking more like
an honorary member I guess you'd say
according to my records the silver vial
should be right over there as soon as
the pearl arrived via Val Thorens
transference spell the right master
gathered the Conclave to prepare an
augury ritual
he's been cycling sages through to keep
them fresh while slowly increasing the
intensity of the ritual I'm the right
masters acolyte I have other duties to
perform besides such a complex ritual
requires the power of the Conclave of
the eleven forces I'm not that strong
yet under the right masters tutelage I
expect to attain that rank one day
[Music]
was orientable to direct you to the
proper elixir without something to
amplify the magic our ritual is going to
fail just in time for the next stage of
the ritual if you have no objections I'd
like you to join us your experiences
alongside thalaron might help reveal
what has so far eluded our efforts will
handle the magic you pour the elixir
into the scrying pool and stand close as
the rituals power amplifies your
experiences with the pearl and the false
alldock should help the augury do its
job we want to discover the origin of
the pearl and its strange magic in
addition anything we can learn about the
false all dark and his connection to the
pearl would be helpful otherwise we're
stepping blindly into Oblivion's ma here
for the elixir into the pool that should
provide the final boost we need to
trigger the augury
here we stand the most favored servants
of clavicle smile the father and
nocturnal on the verge of the greatest
victory for our princes are you sure
those creatures can be trusted have no
fear
isn't that why we've formed the court of
bedlam besides what happens next in
Relan Theo will seal Somerset's fate
that was unnerving
it seems the false alldock belong to an
alliance of Daedric cultists called the
court of bedlam imagine the faithful of
clavicus vile mephala and nocturnal
working together this is more serious
than I anticipated
no but I'm hardly an expert on the
Daedric cults of Tamriel the magic I
sensed in the pearl though it doesn't
contain the taint of oblivion we're
missing something but what I suppose
we'll need to find out what's going on
in Relan teal I hoped you'd say that
Relan Thiel sits to the west of
shimmerin just across the mountains
I'll send Val Suren with you to talk to
the canon read the falls all dark may be
dead of my phallus and Nocturnals agents
remain as well as the pearls
I have
you
[Music]
[Music]
ah this one has been looking for you
razzes investigations have brought into
rel until when this one noticed your
sick friend slip into town Russ figured
you'd be along soon so what did you
discover on our Pam the island that
isn't here anymore
yeah that madrasas head hurt yes this
one has been exploring the Daedric
connection as well but rod hates Deidre
in Roz's experience very little good
comes from dealing with Deidre or their
cultists that is disturbingly vague why
must cryptic cultists be so cryptic well
rostov ulcer in headhorn
cannon reefer
go inside and we'll discuss this later
and take off that ridiculous hood
ridiculous I'll show you what's
ridiculous I'll show you all you think
as Kenan Reeve I'd be immune to the
troubles and temper of a spoiled and
rebellious child but what distinguished
visitors I have today a wandering sage a
well-dressed Khajiit and you what brings
such investigating for who well there
have been three reports this week of
someone disappearing and my intractable
son Nadal and his malcontent friends
have been cavorting around the large
sinkhole that recently appeared what are
you implying they're just young and
proud of their heritage I wouldn't draw
such a harsh conclusion without
substantial evidence I can't understand
why they're fascinated with the sinkhole
but that doesn't make them criminals I
suppose to hi-rez wants to ask the Canon
Reeve a few more questions
take this eg can go investigate the
sinkhole
Dawnbreaker
open the way oh come on
stupid Daedric interference I'll be back
I think we can enter all these rules
you
he attacked and on and one of those
horrible creatures
[Music]
that young woman was certainly yes well
it certainly feels dangerous
the walls and ceiling
more of those larger creatures the size
of this place it's almost as if someone
dug up through the island I'll teleport
closer to the central area and meet you
there
[Applause]
someone there help please help Creasy
it was just the court of bedlam will
eradicate the lesser races maybe even
deal with our unberthing queen
[Music]
over here keep quiet and tell me we'll
see what I see
you see that right my eyes aren't
playing tricks on me that's a violent
dangerous species very powerful the
hooded figure could be a mem they could
certainly have a connection my creatures
destroy the intruders we need weakness
for power guitar on the abyssal Cabo
[Music]
destroy the pearls we can't let those
creatures reach the surface the sea
slowed and the hooded figure are gone to
determine where they disappear to
yeah
damn no sign of whether see snow
disappeared to
damnit for the time being the cease road
left us something to remember it by
we need to dispatch that creature
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
you
30:50 somehow our new fight
these floats this is worse than the
right master maddened meet me not him
after you talked to the Queens I did the
pretty siege x8c slowed sloth that day
there are worshipers in Somerset and
slow
the eye of the queen how dare you accuse
my son of treason the Queen's eye
how dare he not identify himself when he
first arrived and how see slow o Natori
Allah it's what God foolishness can be
ignored murder and prison not so much
you and your queen have no authority
over a true Oprah you mangy cat this one
cannot allow your crimes to stand
unanswered you are he'll no no I
understand
ghrelin Phil is loyal to the Queen
sometimes the eye sees treason and must
cut it out before blasphemy treason
murder how many crimes treason and the
Queen's Justice are seen no Roz will see
you
you
welcome to our Diandra their word me
innocence
friend of answerin I have a proposal for
you friend I'm familiar with that Valdis
the Daedric princes require minions I
asked the Conclave of the 11 forces the
more we learn the more the nature of the
threat becomes